fractional exponents can be a little
daunting at first so it never hurts to
do as many examples as possible so let's
do a few
what if we had
25
over 9 and we wanted to raise it to the
one-half power
so we're essentially just saying well
what is the principle square root of 25
over 9 so what number times itself is
going to be 25 over 9.
well we know 5 times 5 is 25 and 3 times
3 is 9 so why don't we just go with 5
over 3 because notice if you have
5
over 3 times 5 over 3 that is going to
be 25
over 9 or another way of saying this
that 5 over 3 squared is equal to 25
over 9. so 25 over 9 to the one-half is
going to be equal to five-thirds
now let's escalate things a little bit
let's take let's take a really hairy one
let's raise
let's raise 81
over
over
256
81 over 256
to the negative
1
4
power
i encourage you to pause this and try
this on your own
so what's going on here this negative
the first thing i always like to do is i
want to get rid of this negative in the
exponent so let me just take the
reciprocal of this and raise it to the
positive so 1 so i could just say that
this is equal to 256
over 81
to the one-fourth
power and so now i can say well what
number times itself times itself times
itself is going to be equal to 256 and
what number times itself times itself
times itself did i say that four times
well what number if i take four of them
and multiply do i get 81
and one way to think about it this is
going to be the same thing and we'll
talk about this in more depth later on
when we talk about exponent properties
but this is going to be the exact same
thing as 256 to the one-fourth
over 81 to the one-fourth you in fact
saw it over here this over here was the
same thing as the square root of 25 over
the square root of nine or 25 to the
one-half over nine to the one-half so
we're just doing that over here so one
we still have to think about what number
this is so and this is a little bit of
there's no easy way to do this you kind
of have to just play around a little bit
to come up with it but 4 might jump out
at you if you recognize that 16 times 16
is 256 we know that 4 to the 4th power
or you you're about to know this is 4
times 4 times 4 times 4
and 4 times 4 is 16 times 4 is 64 times
4 is equal to 256.
so 4 to the fourth is 256
or we could say 4 is equal to 256 to the
one-fourth power fair enough and what
about 81
well 3 might jump out at you we know
that 3 to the 4th power is equal to 3
times 3 times 3 times 3 which is equal
to 81. so 3 is equal to 81 to the
one-fourth
so this top number
256 to the one-fourth that's just four
eighty-one to the one-fourth
that is just three so this right over
here is going to be equal to
four thirds